[Music]
buckle your seat belts
we're traveling to planet her with dosia
cat
[Music]
it's a little bit like this okay but a
lot more
sharp and edgy and interesting and it's
very
sexy the 25 year old singer delivered an
out of this world performance for her
first year attending the grammys
lots of lasers and space-inspired
costumes
of course accompanied by big vocals and
fierce choreography
[Music]
e.t spoke with doja during rehearsals
for her debut grammy performance where
she hinted that the space vibes would be
strong
so straight off of rehearsals filming
what were we just doing
straight off from rehearsals i'm winded
i am yeah i'm just i'm excited i'm also
flashing my prototype
mic holster which i shouldn't be doing
but that's a spoiler for
something and she playfully teased that
the epic reign of her smash single
say-so
is officially over this is like the
funeral of say so i feel like
you know i'm i'm in my all black you
know this is i got my team some
sweatsuits and all black
e.t was with doja again on sunday just
hours before taking the stage where she
revealed what it felt like to attend her
first
ever grammy awards performing tonight
how excited are you hit the grammy stage
i am overwhelmed i'm i can't believe
that it's gotten to this point and i'm
i'm
very very excited and i just can't wait
for my fans to see
what i've cooked up it's crazy and the
carpet is red
so that's crazy like that that's enough
for me
like i'm just like wow this is insane
like i just am amazed that like i'm here
and like
this is incredible i'll take this any
day